[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on dirait une meuf qui sont qui c'est
incrusté dans un clip de rap
on comprend pas ce qu'elle fait là
déjà des idées de boutiques bien sûr ça
va
[Applaudissements]
on ira d'abord on ira d'abord en
pharmacie acheter des chaussures des
choses
on va se régaler
des spécial pieds sensibles
c'est tellement simple
vous mettez deux dolipranes dès que les
chaussures en 42 ou les amandes
[Musique]
je vous le dis Damart c'est tellement
chaud frère que tu mets même un petit
t-shirt comme ça en V en plein hiver de
balade et ben il te chauffe le corps
maintenant avec des batteries
chauffantes
donc on va se faire un truc j'adore te
chercher chez toi 10h du matin en
voiture dans ma voiture dans ma voiture
avec une décapotable tu aimes les
Citroën bizarres
si vous êtes dedans ça me va pas je suis
là elle vient te chercher
dans la voiture on écoute de la musique
je mets la musique
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et là elle a et là
et là on achète pour commencer j'ai dit
de la tête aux pieds d'abord je vais te
prendre des petites Damas en 41 je fais
du 41 c'est ça
[Rires]
au cas où on prend l'avion
qui remonte dans le sang
[Applaudissements]
après sous-vêtements waouh on va aller
chez culotta
[Rires]
le roi de la culotte espagnole
c'est des culottes en forme d'omelette
la culotte arrive ici fond des culottes
également col roulés
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on ira chez le meilleur le Best le
number one Fabio
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
t'inquiète pas ma chérie
le 12 le 12 quoi décembre
c'est fait
[Applaudissements]